[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to this early morning edition of
the dark horse podcast live stream
we apologize for the early hour to those
of you who live in hawaii we also envy
you for living in hawaii because what a
marvelous place to exist
um it is live stream number 90
is that correct that is correct yes
isn't it amazing how i've begun to
iterate
by adding one each time we do a live
stream and that seems to generate a
pattern that matches your understanding
of what live stream
this is middle-aged dogs learn
little tricks learned old tricks slowly
but
eventually yeah something like that yeah
90 trial learning
90 trial learning that's beautiful i
like that yes 90.
[Laughter]
all right well we have uh lots to do
today and i have a plane to catch later
so um we should probably get to it
indeed let's start with announcements
talk a little bit about where we're
going
uh we've got two ads today and then
we'll launch right into it so we're
gonna talk a bit about um
about about i'm sorry kobe 2 and kovid
um which is getting old and
so old so old and we wish the virus was
getting old
instead it seems to be rejuvenating
itself rather a lot
and we're going to talk about sex and
gender a bit today um the
chapter of the hunter-gatherers of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
uh which is our book coming out in
september that we will be talking about
today is chapter seven
sex and gender so we'll do an excerpt
from that and talk about some issues
arising um those that of course is i
mean as everything in the book but that
is very much a recurring theme for us so
we will come back to it uh
frequently um okay so if you're watching
on youtube
uh consider switching over to odyssey
the link should be
in the uh description i think uh zachary
and if you're listening um don't switch
at all just uh just keep on listening as
you are
uh you can ask questions at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh where there are um facts to uh allow
you to understand what you're doing
please consider joining our patreons um
either or both of them
it helps us out a lot and you get
benefits
including smaller live conversations
with
with brett at two of the higher tiers
and at mine
we do a private q a once a month um
and earlier in the month if you're at a
slightly higher tier you get to ask a
question that we will consider
and those are a lot of fun actually we
did ours last last week i think can i
say it wasn't last week never mind
it was it was in the past um it was in
the past
right how to speak carefully so you
can't possibly be wrong
um i mean it was in the past yeah um
can i add something about the uh okay
but we're not doing that i know
okay uh the patreons i just wanted to
say
that we are very grateful for people
joining those and we know that we have
asked you to
help us out as youtube has
clobbered our main source of income and
you have turned out in force and
we want you to know that we greatly
appreciate you're doing that and that it
enables us
to continue to fight so um thank you for
doing that
okay let me just say that while i was
looking at you our producer came in and
changed something i think and now we
appear to be totally washed out at least
on the camera on the screen that we can
see
washed out but not washed up i couldn't
hear either of you
and learn to love the bomb right right
exactly all right
um okay and um we've those goliath
t-shirts that we
uh that we put out a couple weeks ago
are doing brilliantly on
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
unfortunately they have been copied and
a lot of other people seem to be making
money on our idea as well
yes i want to point out something though
they have been copied
however as far as i know nobody has
figured out
that the punch line is on the back of
the shirt so if you want
the genuine article including the
awesome punchline
check out the store and go look at
what's there and if you want to honor
the creators and uh
put you know support the people who
actually came up with the idea
um please go to our store you'll also
get the actual the actual article
including the back
this week i launched my new sub stack
natural selections you can find that at
naturalselections.substack.com and we'll
be talking about the second post and
that
in the first part of our podcast here
but without further ado we have two ads
for you
today
we are waiting the border that will tell
you that we are engaged
in ads there it is all right
um we're going to start off with our
excellent sponsor public goods
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for high quality everyday
essentials their ingredients are
carefully sourced and affordable public
goods has towels glassware sponges
razors shampoo toilet paper mustard and
coffee
coconut oil and other things that you
need
they've got niche items like bone broth
concentrate gluten-free pasta and small
batch marshmallows and you will find
that their goods are packaged in a
tasteful way so you don't have this
phenomenon of gaudy items accumulating
on your shelves making your shelves look
like a supermarket where everything
has been designed by people who think
that products are also
advertisements now these things look
good and they do not call attention to
themselves
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple
and easy to use public goods members can
buy all of their premium essentials in
one place
it really is an everything store for
dark horse listeners
we have the following offer receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again that they are
giving you
15 to spend on your first purchase with
no minimum
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse
use the code darkhorse at checkout that
is public goods p u b l i c g o
o d s dot com forward slash
darkhorse to receive 15 off your first
order
all right and i am going to bring to you
our sponsor omax cryofreeze
uh omax cryofreeze uh is
provides pain relief so let me first say
a few words about pain
it's useful pain is adaptive it's a
signal from your body that something is
amiss
or has been pushed too hard but
sometimes pain is too much
especially in our modern world with the
hyper novelty hyper novel environments
to which we expose ourselves
um and as long as you don't push
yourself
harder after alleviating your pain it
can be useful under some circumstances
um to get rid of it and in fact it can
just allow you to
to live your life if you have chronic
pain that's all the more true
chronic pain can be debilitating we
understand and there is little upside
so i for instance have been spending far
too much time at my computer typing
uh and my hands in positions that as
everyone now knows are not neutral or
not particularly good for you
i've been told that i've got the
equivalent of both tennis and golf elbow
without
actually having enjoyed the pleasures of
either tennis or golf now i've never
enjoyed the pleasures of golf but
um you know it seems to me that if one
is to get those things one should
actually have enjoyed the
the um the fun that they are named for
but nope
this is from typing uh so uh omax
cryofreeze
though um provides uh temporary quick
relief uh for
for the pain uh when i need it to go
away and
as for the product itself it's easy to
use it doesn't smell it's not greasy or
sticky or gooey it rolls right on it
dries quickly
and it's 100 natural and it has menthol
and it has cbd
one of the ingredients in marijuana not
the one that gets you high
it's designed to block pain receptors
reduce inflammation and improve muscle
and joint flexibility
so omax health is offering our listeners
20
off a full bottle of cryo freeze cbd
pain relief
roll on which is the product that i have
used this discount also applies though
towards any product site-wide
just go to omaxhealth.com today and
enter the code
darkhorse that's omax health.com
and enter the code darkhorse to get 20
off cryofreeze and
sitewide
and uh in service of um
being on youtube and feeling that
youtube is uh infantilizing its viewers
a little bit by making decisions about
what it is that uh
that we should and should not be allowed
to see today's episode is brought to you
by the number 90
and also the letter g and uh while we
are going through these chapters
of our book uh one at a time up until
the the launch day in mid-september
um the letter g um is
uh is in i'm going to read the index for
the letter
g i every i'm not sure i can go wild i'd
but i'll do my oh you gotta
okay so letter the g
g index from our book gasoline gato
john taylor excellent guy gay men
generalists
genes genome cultures genome expression
regulator epigenetic
genital mutilation genocide geographic
frontiers germ theory of disease
gestation gibbons i don't know why
glossary is in the glossary that's funny
i feel like that's an error i
just spun myself into it we will know
something has gone wrong if the first
copy catches fire wow
gluten sensitivity glycoalkaloids gmos
golden-colored mannequins
golden lion tamarins totally different
kinds of organisms there
good all jane good samaritan story
gorillas great bowerbirds grief group
stability growth
guatemalan farmers and last but not
least guinea yams
glossary see glossary
i missed that the first time around
amazing all right um
i think that's it for our uh
announcements and stuff do we want to
start um
here or um we could let me
maybe i'll say a word of uh a word of
precursor before that i will just say
um we have received a ton of pushback as
you've seen which is not unusual and
actually
in general i would say pushback is
useful
and something i think we
we like but the kind of pushback we're
getting is
remarkable a lot of it is quite um
vicious and
unkind i would say and i must say it has
put me in the frame of mind
of let's say
staring into the abyss and when one
stares into this particular abyss what
one sees
is what physicists might call a quantum
superposition
do you continue to fight for what makes
sense
or do you walk away and do something
else
and so it's sort of a it's an either or
kind of a decision
which means as you stare into the abyss
and you look at this
question of what to do it's like a
simultaneous
or chasm oh no that wasn't worth it
it wasn't worth it nope oh no i thought
it was actually pretty good i think the
delivery was bad but
okay um this is actually both a good pun
and a correct reflection i think of
uh what the experience is like it's the
second put all of us through that
for that delivery dude there were people
groaning across the earth i think that
was worth it
no no i don't because in fact um
we we are going to be talking about all
this a little bit
less but not for the reasons that you
just described so i mean i think i think
that's a setup that
presents the wrong the wrong idea
well i mean i accept what you're saying
and i obviously you and i have talked
about this
and i i agree but
i also think well i don't know my sense
is
that terrible pun that groan-worthy pun
is also uh in some sense an accurate
reflection
at least of my personal sense of
where we are okay well some people don't
have any idea what we're talking about
because no
no content words have been said there's
no nouns in
in what what you've said okay so can we
can we just
show this let's do it and um and then
you can launch into what you're going to
launch into so zach
um as i said i launched natural
selections this week the very first post
is called fact checkers aren't
scientists too often they're sensors
and the second one which is co-written
by brett and me on driving sars kovi to
extinct why we need a multi-pronged
approach
this is very we just published this
yesterday evening
it's very long sometimes technical not
as much fun as a lot of what i'm going
to be posting on natural selections
but it serves both as the response
to that misinformation-filled
article that was published by berlin
skin deegan and colette a few years ago
and also to some degree by the um
response to the
sam harrison eric topple podcast that we
talked about last week which
largely i you know they there weren't a
lot of errors
introduced by them that i think they
didn't pick up from the quality article
um so um this in in this piece
it is it is not the original draft was
really a sort of
a rebuttal but we decided you know what
this is this is not what we should be
doing this is not what anyone should be
doing
what we should be doing is laying out
what we see is the evidence what we see
is where evidence is missing where we
need
more why we need clarifications so that
all of us
can actually remember that we are on the
same team
on the same planet and that we need to
have
policies that actually serve all of us
maximally so far as that is possible
and so what we lay out here um are
really um i guess six six different
sort of organizational frameworks uh
organizational topics
uh we explain why why it is that we've
landed where we have
by going through the evidence for the
effectiveness
as of ivermectin as prophylaxis against
covid
the safety record of hypermectin the
safety record of the novel coronavirus
vaccines
and the effectiveness of the novel
coronavirus vaccines we then talk some
about natural immunity
um and why people with natural immunity
um are not being considered in the
discussion rather we are being presented
by
the media for instance with these with
this simplistic
and frankly absurd dichotomy of
vaccinated versus unvaccinated
and we speak some to the politicization
of of the discussion
and um just a little bit more on some of
the some of the many errors that are in
um that are in some of the pieces that
have been produced
as if they are good faith criticisms and
you know as we
as we have said many times um
you know we we need we want everyone
should need and want good faith
criticism
but at the point that your critics are
making false claims about what it is
that you yourselves have said or done or
believe
that should tell you more about the
critics than it tells you about you
so yes it's one of it's one of two
things that i find particularly
disturbing about the critics is
um having to portray us as believing
things and having said things that we
didn't believe
or don't believe and didn't say um is
obviously
evidence of something and we can talk
about what it's evidence of but it's
clearly
you know uh having to defend against
straw man attacks is obviously uh crazy
making but there's also this question
about um the implications
right what we are being held responsible
for i find
uh particularly onerous and
uh destructive so in essence you will
find many people saying well
you know lives are at stake and what
you're saying
on your podcast is going to result in
the death of people
and this is um on the one hand
as we ourselves have said before anyone
else said it
about us obviously there are lives at
stake and so we take this very
seriously on the other hand it is
cheating
to hold us responsible for this the
correct
honorable way to do this is to recognize
that lives
are at stake in the public health policy
questions
and your personal health decisions with
respect
to how you choose to protect yourself
from covid that is true
what that means is that a great deal
rests
on how the evidence is interpreted and
it is true
you can certainly protect yourself from
the accusation
that you will be responsible for other
people's
health consequences and possibly deaths
by not saying anything that's true
you can simply not say anything or you
can embrace
the conventional wisdom as dispensed by
public health authorities
and then who could possibly hold you
responsible on the other hand
you've watched those public health
officials fail
again and again and again and we can
talk about why they might be failing
there are at least
two reasons on the table one of them is
incompetence
inability to read what is taking place
in the world
the other is corruption which is
something that you and i have talked
about
from the beginning and both of these
things
are rendering the advice we are being
given publicly
feeble so the question is what to do
about it
if you're in a position like we are in
do you talk about what you see
or do you keep quiet so is not to be
blamed
right now my feeling is we are morally
required
to the extent that we believe we can see
something that is failing about the
public health analysis we are morally
required to engage in talking about this
you are not required to listen you are
certainly not required to extrapolate
from anything that we say on this
podcast and adjust your behavior
you can just listen into a discussion
imagine it's a seminar taking place
in which we are talking about whether or
not the public health analysis makes any
sense
now if you find yourself persuaded by
something that we say it may indeed
affect your behavior but that's because
you have been persuaded we don't have
the power to dictate any policy nobody
has to follow
what we're saying nobody has to listen
in so people are choosing to listen in
they are rightly frightened by the fact
that the advice they are getting from
public health officials
doesn't add up not even superficially
and so i would just simply ask it is not
the case
that we are putting people's lives at
risk it is the case that lives are at
stake
in the covet pandemic and that it is
true that lives will be lost if we do
the wrong things and not the right
things the question is
what are the right things and how would
you know
now what do you do in a case where you
have rampant corruption
and i do think one of the things that is
afflicting people's
um comprehension of what's taking place
here is that many people
who have not been inside academia or
conversely are so
deeply enmeshed in it that they are
dependent on it are incapable of seeing
that the
same corruption that has rendered our
governmental structures
so thoroughly broken so that they do the
bidding of others instead of the bidding
of the public
that same thing is true inside of
academia
more subtly it makes its way into papers
it makes its way into analyses it makes
its way
into the advice that we get from many
people who are involved in that
structure but you can't see it and if it
hasn't been your home
you don't recognize it so you think
somehow you think
everybody on earth must all be agreed
that the right thing to do is to drive
zara's cov2 to extinction or at least
manage it really well and that must be
the source of all of this advice but i'm
telling you that can't possibly be right
it can't be what's generating this
advice because in many places
that that advice doesn't add up even
superficially
so there are certain questions that i
would advise you keep your eye on
certain things that tell you that
something other than public health or
private well-being is driving the policy
why are we argued why are we told that
we should vaccinate those
who are naturally immune as a result of
having had sars cov2
already that doesn't make any sense we
know that the immunity you get from the
vaccines is narrower
and we know that it fades we now know
that it fades
two why are we treating the young in
the same way that we are treating the
old with respect to the need to
vaccinate
there's obviously a very different
cost-benefit ratio and why are we not
using
safe tools that appear to have some
effectiveness to close the gap
left by the vaccines those the vaccines
can't reach those the vaccines won't
reach
those who need treatment because they
have a breakthrough case why wouldn't we
use those things
all right you wanted to say something no
you moved on
um you sure okay
so i wanted to make a couple of points
the defense that we need is simply that
we are
trying to do the right thing right this
is well understood in the law there are
many places where good samaritans are
protected
for engaging in behavior intended to
help rather than harm even if harm is
done
that is the defense necessary for what
we are up to we do not
have some other thing motivating us in
fact we have
paid a very substantial price for
speaking out publicly on this topic and
we would ask
that you just simply recognize that
whether we are right or wrong
we are intending to do good and we are
also
interested as we make very clear in the
piece that we published yesterday
we are focused on the long-term
well-being of humanity that means not
just the well-being of people who are
alive today but people who will be alive
generations from now who either will
have to deal with sars kobe 2 continuing
to circulate in some
new form or won't because we've
succeeded in driving it to extinction
that's a deep question we have an
obligation to them they cannot speak for
themselves we have to act on their
behalf
and so oh go ahead well i guess i will
say to to your
to your point about um
institutional capture with regard to
academia
the way you talked about it it sounded
like people will be shocked to hear
that academia has has become captured
and in fact you know most of our
audience will be well familiar with that
concept
um but in a limited frame right in uh
in in the frame of grievance studies
right and also you know administrators
you know there are a lot of ways that
people have begun to become familiar
with the idea that actually higher ed
isn't what it's supposed to be and it's
helping to destroy and make fragile
excuse me and make fragile um you know
so many of the people who go through
higher ed at this point
uh and indeed uh we we have even um
year years ago a few years ago uh at the
point that our friends
you know the people who who did the
grievance studies where peter bogosian
and helen pluck rose and james lindsey
were were doing that we were saying
yes for sure we see that we see we see
the sort of the
the bastardization of postmodernism from
the 90s and those people
coming around and you know becoming
faculty now and
indoctrinating rather than educating
students and it's a you know that's a
big part of the explanation of what went
wrong at evergreen and what is you know
all of the you know the big ridiculous
kerfuffles on college campuses seem to
be about that
but what we said then and was harder to
convince people of who aren't actually
in the sciences was
there is a different problem within the
sciences
it's been brewing for longer it's about
the the
the economic model of how scientists and
um
scientists are funded and how
institutions are funded by those
scientists therefore providing perverse
incentives for scientists to only do
do big science expensive science and
it has rendered scientists also
not just people with phds and fields
that probably shouldn't exist
but many scientists incapable of
actually doing
solid careful evolutionary thought and
so
credentialism as it rises where people
say well you know
that person is a professor that person
has a phd in a science they must know
what they're talking about
the number of people who actually have
these degrees
and were never expected in fact to get
those degrees
to do a complete piece of research from
beginning to end to make an observation
to pose all the alternative the possible
alternative hypotheses
to figure out how you might address
those hypotheses what the predictions
that are downstream of them are and how
you would address them
and what the experimental design would
be and go out and collect the data and
analyze
the data and figure out what it means
and reveal it and communicate it both in
speech and in writing
many people don't experience that in
order to get their phd they walk into
someone else's lab
with someone else's funding with someone
else's questions already on the table
and they do a little tiny piece and
why do we expect people like that to be
able to think broadly about the entire
scientific process and to walk in and
say
actually that that doesn't make sense
actually
actually you know when you when you do
um widespread vaccination with
non-sterilizing vaccines during a
pandemic
there is likely to be selective pressure
for new variants to
uh to start to spread and this is
something that we've talked about before
that you had on garrett vandenbush to
talk about he's been talking about it
there's a paper that that we cite in
what we just published
from 2015 that goes through the long
established theoretical considerations
for why to think that
and the fact that there are lots of
models out there that demonstrate it but
then they also do the empirical work
and they're looking at chickens and they
find
indeed that um the that non-sterilizing
vaccines
produce an environment uh that actually
helps the
spread of new variants of of of
previously um unfamiliar and rare
variants
so i want to go back to the the place
that you started i agree with everything
you've just said
it's vital but the the piece i want to
highlight
is the um
when the the um the grievance studies
work emerged
we actually did say to them um
the problem is you didn't
do this with the sciences also and so
you can't see
that the that there is a parallel kind
of corruption
in the sciences that the scientific work
is not pure and in contrast
right the the grievance study stuff is
particularly egregious and obvious it's
transparently wrong
the problem is that the scientific stuff
is cryptically
broken and you know it's not just the
fact that these people have been
awarded a degree for work that doesn't
actually make them expert in the way
science is done because they've done too
small a piece that's a common problem
but there's also this issue the same
reason that people end up doing a very
small
piece of work in order to get their
degree is that there's this incredible
pressure that has to do with the way the
university is
is paying for its its work by
effectively
giving people degrees in lieu of money
that's how it makes
uh itself profitable and so that creates
this incredible pressure to do work that
pleases those in a position of authority
in order to um to get any hope of a job
and so what you get are these positive
feedbacks where some bit of conventional
wisdom the school of thought that owns
your field
is in a position to make sure that only
work that matches that school of thought
and doesn't challenge it emerges so it
becomes
anti-scientific and until you've seen
the effect of that corruption
you it seems it's impossible to imagine
and frankly
that that truth about how science is
funded and has been for decades at this
point at least in the in the western
world certainly in the us and the uk
and canada as well and i think more
widespread than that
that necessarily preceded the
rise in the grievan studies fields and
the capture
by them of many university
administrations
because scientists are encouraged to and
i've talked about this on a previous on
a previous episode
but because scientists are basically the
the money makers for universities
because the universities get such a
substantial
overhead percentage of any grants that
get brought in
they are given effectively scientists um
academic scientists are given the gift
of not having to do some of the other
work that they would have to do and
broadly there's three sorts of things
that academics are expected to do it's
research it's teaching and it's
governance
governance meaning everything from
sitting on the committee that decides
who's going to
do the catering for your campus to
admissions to hiring
to decisions about um you know
restructuring of organizations
of departments and and schools within
your campus
um well if the if the money's coming in
because of your research you're not
going to give
research science a research scientist to
pass on the research but you're going to
start
to minimize what they have to do in
those other two camps
and so you give them fewer teaching
responsibilities which also means they
have less and less
interaction with with students who are
actually
incredibly useful in terms of giving yes
a bunch of naive pushback but also a lot
of sophisticated pushback because they
don't know what questions they're not
supposed to ask
so that's a drawback of being less
exposed to the
the teaching part of it but it's even
easier to say okay you you don't have
you know
the more money you bring in the more
focused you are on that we understand
you're busy you don't have to do as much
governance
which means the governance positions are
filled more and more
there's there is there is
representation within governance at many
universities that is widely skewed
towards non-scientists and towards
people in fields that are actually not
making any sense at all
and so all the grievance studies
kerfuffle is actually downstream
of this failure of scientists to
continue to be scientists but instead be
captured by these economic forces
right and effectively what we're saying
is you can see the effect of capture
inside the academy and of course it has
a particularly academic
look to it in that context it looks very
different than whatever takes place
where
lobbyists are persuading legislators to
do things but the point is it's a
variation on a theme
and one thing that just occurs to me at
this moment
is you and i have observed in traveling
in other parts of the world especially
developing nations that one of the
things that makes it impossible to
govern these nations
is that everybody is so pressed for
resources that they're very cheap to
corrupt
right so you've got somebody who's in
charge of forest policy in madagascar
let's say and they
maybe they make 10 000 bucks a year
right i don't know now but it wasn't
anything close to that
let's say they make 10 000 bucks and
let's say that
uh they're supposed to prevent you from
logging some
peninsula and there are tens of millions
of dollars at stake in the lumber there
and the question is well how easy are
they to persuade
to betray their public obligation if
it's going to actually enable them
to to you know put their family on
on a substantial footing it's very hard
to prevent that kind of corruption
when people are not made immune by
having decent salaries
and so this is exactly the case inside
of
academia you've got this incredible
insecurity that comes from the fact that
there aren't nearly enough jobs and the
fact is it
causes people to be easily corrupted
even if that they don't understand what
they're doing there's no
bribe on the table but there are many
many other mechanisms yeah well i mean
there it's
it's not a it's usually not a physical
thing but it's offers
of of of goodies right in academia and
i'm you know the
it will be obvious that it's a bribe
when i say that when i was going through
all of the normal channels and doing
everything by the book and i really
wasn't cheating at all
and trying to get the permits that i
needed to do the work i i needed to do
in madagascar i was asked
by the person with the stamp like
literally it was a stamp right i
remember us having to wait for three
days to get into this room
um where the guy with the stamp was
finally going to show up at the same
time as the stamp one day the guy wasn't
there the next day the stamp wasn't
there the third day like well the keys
to the door weren't there and he was
going to have to go in the i mean it was
it was a comedy of errors but actually
true
um but you know i had done everything
correctly i was not trying to cheat the
system at all but
um and in a different time when i was
trying to get the permits for a
different field season in madagascar i
got asked for a land rover
well i was a graduate student making at
that point you know 13 dollars a year
and i didn't have a land rover nor did i
have any um
inclination to give the guy land rover
if i had one
um but he accepted in lieu of a land
rover a bottle of whiskey
which i came back with the next day well
which i had to should also say
but that's an obvious set up like right
that's how we think it's going to look
but in academia it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't look that way i
should just say that the land rover
sounds preposterous except that we knew
cases in which land rovers had been used
because some large
project with a million dollar grant
needed to get some stuff done and you
might as well ask
right so yeah maybe she has a land rover
right so
the problem is that the corruption of
science which is because it's subtle
it's very destructive because we can't
even it's very hard to even diagnose
like which
stuff do you trust right that's that's a
that's a harder job than it should be
but the overarching corruption anywhere
where there's something
at stake like money right like this is
liable to be much less of a problem and
uh i'm going to find out that i'm wrong
if i say geology because maybe
mineral resources but if you you know
presumably
astronomy is going to be better about
the kind of corruption it's going to
have a kind of
mundane corruption and then things get
really bad as i discovered when i did
the telomere work
as you get closer to medicine right
things get really corrupt and messed up
but the the the overarching
impact of that corruption in all of its
forms
is to render the science feeble
right which has a paradoxical weird
effect that if you don't
want to win in its terms is actually
something you can make use of
right it means that field after field
which is corrupted
are relatively easy to beat right if
you're free of the influences that
corrupt it you can look in and you can
say
this makes sense that doesn't add up and
you can begin
to follow a pattern and so what i would
say is one of the things that i think we
are faced with here
is that in effect we have no power
we are not telling you do this or don't
do that we are just simply talking about
what we see and
i'm sure some people are persuaded i
know lots of people aren't i mean we
have conversations in
uh in the patreon discussions that i
have once a month we've talked about
vaccination i think almost everybody in
those discussions is vaccinated as we
could have ended up vaccinated if we
hadn't been paying attention to certain
signals that became
alarming a little quickly but the point
is
why would somebody listen to us at all
well one reason that they would listen
to us
is that we have actually seen a head
and that if you listen to us you were
ahead on thinking about masks you were
ahead i'm thinking about
the importance of the volume of the room
in terms of
infection from covid you were ahead in
thinking about
variance you were ahead in seeing the
narrowness of the immunity that was
likely to come from
spike protein s1 subunit vaccinations
you were ahead in recognizing the
outdoor environment
as safe and some place that you should
go you were ahead in recognizing
the importance of vitamin d you were
ahead with respect to the lab leak
hypothesis
you were ahead with respect to the
massive significance of comorbidities
that's not even a complete list that's
just a bunch of places where if you were
watching us you were paying attention to
these things really early at the very
least and so
i will just finish this by saying
for some reason when we talk about
things like foreign policy we have a
term
for war profiteers right
war war profiteers nobody gets all bent
out of shape they don't accuse you of
conspiracy theorizing if you say there
are war profiteers and we need to beware
that they may have an effect on our
foreign policy that could push us into
wars that we would be better off
staying out of everybody gets that even
when there are lives
at stake in the context of war that
there are people whose perverse
incentives might cause them
to mislead us why do we not understand
that that same thing is at least
plausible with respect
to a pandemic are there pandemic
profiteers if so
what might they have us do that we
shouldn't do this is something
we need to ask ourselves and our ability
to predict things
is something you could judge us on but
you at least need to recognize that
we are in a landscape where potentially
people have perverse incentives that
might lead us to do things that will
result in
um in deaths that don't need to occur
if i can just restate in a sentence what
you just said profiteer
is a general category and war profiteer
is a subcategory that is well understood
uh to be uh to be out there regardless
of whether or not you believe that
you know incident x or y was an example
of it
uh war profiteering is a sub-category of
profiteering and so what you're saying
is there are of course other types of
profiteering
and pandemic profiteering is likely to
be one of them
right it's likely to be one of them and
frankly it's not a very big leap from
what we've seen
from the pharmaceutical industry in
other contexts we know
that very often we see advice we know
that it makes it into the academic
literature and then is only later
revealed to be harming people
so come on what part of this is shocking
right the question is how much of an
effect is it having
on the public health advice that we are
getting and
one thing to pay attention to is the
public health advice
doesn't make sense right i'm not saying
none of it makes sense but a lot of it
doesn't make sense
even on its face why are we vaccinating
people who've had covet that's a
question i've not heard a good answer to
and the cdc's answer you can look it up
doesn't make any sense why is that is
that ineptitude
or is it corruption right could be
either could be both
but at some level it's a question that
needs an answer and until it has an
answer there's a
there's some issue about how bad is that
rot
whatever rot it is that resulted in us
putting people
in harm's way giving them a vaccine we
don't know very much about with respect
to the safety
when they don't get a benefit from it
why would we do that well we could we
could prevent them from taking that risk
and the fact that we don't raises a
question how bad is the rot
how far does it go and one indication is
if others outside of that apparatus are
predicting things about the pandemic
better than that apparatus does then
that is a reason for alarm
so we're we're most of the way through
an hour at this point and we have a lot
to do that's not about this but i think
i thought the place you wanted to start
is someplace you haven't even gotten to
yet
so um do you want to do you want to go
there without me
stealing your thunder yeah i think so um
so i wanted to uh
gently respond to something uh published
by andrew
sullivan that i i believe came out
yesterday i at least saw it yesterday
um do you want to show it yeah exactly
you have the couple
you can put it on my screen okay so that
this is andrew sullivan's piece
yesterday and actually zach could you
show that
the screenshot i sent of his tweet
and then could you enlarge
so this is a quote from uh
boy i can read it yeah you would you
read it so what am i reading though
is this andrew yes this is andrew
sullivan this is a quote from andrew
sullivan this is andrew sullivan in his
piece posted yesterday
and this seems to me to be the key
question here do we really want to get
back to living
i do so take the rational precautions a
solid vaccine
and go about your business as you always
did yes i'll wear a mask indoors if i'm
legally required or politely asked
but i don't really see why anyone should
in a free society once everyone has
access to a vaccine
that overwhelmingly prevents serious
sickness and death there is no reason to
enforce lockdowns again
or mask mandates or social distancing
any longer
in fact there's every reason not to
so what i wanted to say and i uh this is
offered
with um full respect andrew i really
like a lot of what you say and frankly i
understand and resonate with the point
that you are making here
i get it but i don't think it's right
because it's predicated on a couple of
things
that aren't accurate uh so
you are imagining that you are being
asked a cdc yesterday
or the day before said that it wanted
people who had been vaccinated
to wear masks why that's the question
now the answer that many people are
arriving at the answer that i believe we
are being led to is that you are wearing
them to protect
unvaccinated people and there is a
degree of truth in
your wearing a mask protects
unvaccinated people
but i think the clearest reason why you
are being asked to wear a mask is to
protect
you a vaccinated person from the escape
variants that we now see circulating
and secondly from uh do you want to jump
um the first reason for you to wear a
mask as a vaccinated person is to
protect you
against the escape variants which are on
the rise
and about which the vaccines with which
you've already been vaccinated are very
little protection
our very little protection which points
to selection exerted by those vaccines
on the virus so we are ultimately going
to find ourselves in an
argument about evolutionarily why we are
seeing variants now what their
implication is but the fact that those
variants
are good at creating breakthrough cases
among the vaccinated implies selection
by those vaccines has produced these
variants
that's one reason that you need to be
protected at this moment more
than the cdc recognized you did a month
ago
the second reason has to do with the
fading
of the immunity from the vaccines so
these vaccines it turns out not only do
they provide a narrow immunity
but they also provide a short-lived
immunity that appears to fade
so in oh go ahead
uh well i thought you wanted to show
this evidence as well as your third
reason
yeah there's and i was going to say
there is there is also
a third reason so in your piece
andrew you repeat a piece of wisdom
that has been almost universally
embraced
and this piece of wisdom is the vaccines
protect you from getting an infection
they are not perfect
they also protect you from getting
sick protect you from getting very sick
if you do contract a breakthrough
infection now what we want to call your
attention to
is a piece that emerged two days ago
yeah two or three two or three days ago
on sub stack
by a creature euphemistically called
okay
um what zach showed my screen when i was
not ready for it to be shown that's all
right okay
um this was published by dr rollergator
who i should point out is not
actually a phd as far as i know he's
also not an actual alligator
and his leather jacket is fake but
his analysis this is a person who has
published a very serious analysis
of so this is a person you know to be a
real person yes
i do know him to be a part a person uh
and a ferociously high quality intellect
but anyway he has a uh an ironic
personality on twitter which he is using
for his sub stack as well
in any case it is an analysis of the
question of the benefits of the vaccines
and what he
posits here based on a thorough
mathematical analysis
that appears to us at least to be robust
is
uh the question about what the vaccines
do in the case of breakthrough cases do
they
reduce the likelihood of getting
seriously ill
so if i could have my screen back for a
minute zach i was just looking something
up um
what he is if i can just i'm just going
to read the section here rather than
us um so this is this is now from our
piece that we published yesterday the
little bit of it in which we are talking
about his
um in this off-sited study um
which is hassetal 2021 looking at the
effectiveness of the two-dose pfizer
vaccine in israel
they purport to find extremely high
effectiveness against both infections
and in breakthrough cases in reducing
hospitalization severe disease and death
and that that is the work that has been
transmuted into the into the mainstream
media and
the largely the reason why um people
who are vaccinated feel safe um not just
against getting the disease once they're
vaccinated but
in having a reduced a reduced case of it
should they get a breakthrough case
but but dr rollergater here provides an
analysis
in which he finds that
it is true that um the risk of infection
is far lower in vaccinated than in
unvaccinated individuals
however if a person is both vaccinated
and infected
the correct math reveals no reduction in
deaths compared to being unvaccinated
and unless you are old and with regard
to hospitalizations there is a tiny
reduction in hospitalization for the
uh 45 to 64 year olds and
a larger reduction for the old um but
for people under 45
um again no reduction at all so let's
just show his his graphs here this is
regard to
with regard to death the probability of
covet 19 related death if infected
for ages 16 to 14. basically the
um the confidence interval i
think this is i'm not remembering um is
much broader for the vaccinated but
um but they're effectively the same
thing
and that is to say their their mean is
the same
yep and um for
uh hold on so that was 16 to 44 year
olds
uh for 45 to 64 year olds
there is a
you know it looks like a slightly higher
rate of death if you're vaccinated but
really the you know the numbers are
are sloppy enough that there's no reason
to think that that is true
but there's certainly no protective
effect if you get a breakthrough case
um but that's but that flips um
for the for the old for 65 years and
older people
you do indeed have both and this is just
deaths and i'm not going to
scroll through and find the
hospitalization graphs that that he has
produced here
but if you're over 65 and you get a
breakthrough case
because you're vaccinated but you get
exposed to covenant a breakthrough case
being vaccinated does um
does predict a better outcome with
regard to you not dying and you're not
being hospitalized
but for people younger than that that
pattern
falls apart right so uh let's say
this work has just emerged it will be
interesting to see if anyone finds a
flaw in it
but the basic point that that this paper
makes
is that in fact what we are being given
is something like a sales pitch
in which the reduction in deaths and
hospitals paper relegators paper yes
relegators giving a sales pitch no he is
alleging that we are being given a sales
pitch
and the sales pitch is that you have a
reduced
likelihood of infection a reduced
likelihood of severe disease
and a reduced likelihood of
hospitalization and death when in fact
those are the same reduction
that is to say if you don't get coveted
you obviously won't go to the hospital
for covet and you won't die of covet but
it is not
that if you get an infection you also
have a much reduced likelihood of these
things
you don't unless you're in this very old
age group
right exactly so effectively then the
way
that the numbers were analyzed um
amounts to either um
just a naive misunderstanding of how
they should have been analyzed or
hopefully not an intentional
uh erroneous signal put into the world
right but but
i think the the point about uh andrew
sullivan's piece
is that you can see even in that quote
that we read
that what he is imagining is that
he's going to go about his life and if
he gets a case
it's going to be much reduced and so why
should he be wearing a mask and the
answer is a
because your likelihood of getting a
case is going up as a result of the
fading of the vaccine immunity
as a result of the narrowness of that
immunity and the
variants that are now increasingly
dominating the pandemic
and the benefit that he's imagining
should he get a case
is likely to be uh
close to non-existent if this analysis
is correct yeah
so he's not he's not elderly right so i
guess the sum total of all of this the
way i would sum it up
is i believe we have to recognize that
we have been
given a bunch of intuitive sounding
wrong
things that many people believe right we
are
facing increasing frustration and in
fact i believe
we can see an orchestrated campaign to
blame the unvaccinated
for the continuing pandemic as if there
was ever a plan
in which these vaccines were going to
end the pandemic which is inconceivable
in light of the fact
that even if you were to vaccinate all
of the western world
you couldn't reach the entire world with
these things which meant there was going
to be large populations
that were going to continue to have this
virus so you needed effectively
sterilizing vaccines
that were rolled out simultaneously
everywhere
and um and you know i hope that
um we all wish that we had sterilizing
facts absolutely
um and you know we arrived at the
pandemic
with the vaccines that showed up sort of
um and you know
still hoping for you know good solid
sterilizing vaccines to show up
that would be great um but also the way
that these vaccines were rolled out at
least in the u.s
was very slow and
if you know you will remember it was you
know it's healthcare there were all
these tears it was healthcare workers
first and the elderly and people with
comorbidities and people were
were you know vying to to break rank and
and get vaccinated early but there just
wasn't enough to go around
and had the goal been to eradicate the
virus and stop the pandemic
there would have been a concerted effort
to to
wait until there was enough vaccine
supply and concentrate the vaccine
rollout so that as
many people as possible got vaccinated
all at once
as opposed to providing this sort of
rolling target
for selection to act on right so you can
imagine it like if we
really had non-corrupt highly competent
public health
authorities you would imagine that as
painful as it would be to delay
vaccination because of course there
would be lives lost in the interim
that there would have been a delay to
allow a sudden
deployment of the vaccines universally
there would have been special guidance
around
how to behave while you were developing
immunity
so even in the case of a sterilizing
vaccine the period of time in which
you're developing immunity
is a hazard so you know you know i did
see i mean that
the the guidance was until you are
considered fully immunized which was
uh two weeks after your final um shot if
you've got the two-shot
vaccine you need to behave as if you're
not well but
behave as if you're not doesn't doesn't
begin to cover it um so
my point is we could have really high
quality guidance
and the really high quality guy we could
have really high quality vaccines
maybe that's harder to get to yeah i'm
not
we don't know we don't know but we
should we should certainly we hope that
there is r
d um under g going on right now for high
quality sterilizing vaccines would be
lovely but it would also be lovely to
imagine that there's not going to be a
fight between manufacturers over whose
vaccine has the market and that that
fight is going to have very little to do
with which
vaccines are best for humanity i hate to
say it that may sound cynical but given
what i've seen
uh i i would expect jockeying for
position
endemic profiteering right pandemic
profiteering is what i was expect would
expect
but you could imagine very brief
guidance right that you would get
vaccinated you would coordinate with uh
your family maybe and you know isolate
completely for some period of time
i i don't know what the we we would
really want high quality analysis
um but you could imagine a campaign but
this campaign does not look like it was
designed
in any way that anyone could have
imagined it was going to end the
pandemic and yet that's kind of been the
implication
that we would have ended the pandemic if
only it weren't for the holdouts and
that's just nonsense
it can't be right yep
should we pivot yep all right um
we're gonna talk about sex and gender a
little bit all right all right
uh we're gonna start with this excerpt
from
chapter 7 of a hunter-gatherer's guide
to 21st century
uh chapter being sex and gender i'm
going to read a
what is it you actually chose this
section this week so we actually read
the audio we recorded the audio book
this week
both of us are going to be
doing that when that comes out september
14th um
so i already read this aloud once this
week um but this is the section you
chose from the sex and gender chapter
called
division of labor already in the chapter
we've walked through
sort of all of the all of the basic
biology and evolutionary biology of what
sex is what sexual reproduction is why
there's two
you know why we don't change sex all of
that division of labor
in many modern households women clean
the floors and men take out the trash
in some households those roles might be
switched and it might be true that both
members of a pair bond spend equal time
doing domestic work
but it's fairly rare for both partners
to do every domestic task in equal
measure
this is division of labor from many
angles the division of labor makes sense
it has even been argued that division of
labor by the sexes is what made us human
even if we don't accept that conclusion
we can agree that it's efficient
and generally a good use of everyone's
time saving time by dividing up the work
leaves more time for things we might
want to do more of like
play or sex the division of labor can
and has created rigid roles however
many of which are outdated in the 21st
century it is useful to understand some
of where those roles
came from in order to determine which
ones are unlikely to change
and which ones might from the earliest
inequalities in investment in gametes
females and males have engaged each
other and the world differently
among hunter-gatherers men have been far
more likely to be hunters of large game
women more likely to be gatherers of
plant foods and smaller animals
hunter-gatherer women likely spent most
of their adult premenopausal lives
pregnant or breastfeeding infants and
toddlers
when breast milk is all or most of a
child's diet the mother is effectively
on birth control
as she experiences physiologically
induced amenorrhea
she cannot get pregnant when
breastfeeding at frequent intervals
this keeps birth intervals relatively
long and the birth rate fairly low
jump forward to the human transformation
of landscapes with agriculture
and gender roles become even more
constrained being tied to a particular
piece of land we were now more sedentary
and had ample grain stories with which
to supplement our and our children's
diets at any time
agriculturalist women thus experienced a
decrease in the birth interval
babies came at a faster rate and so the
birth rate climbed
this increase in fertility tied women to
hearth and home and we saw a concomitant
i decrease it's kind of competent i
think so too yeah
we saw a concomitant decrease in women's
roles in economic
religious and other culturally important
realms
men and women exhibit so many
differences it would be impossible to
catalog them all here before we mention
just a few more another reminder about
populations is an order
when we say that men are taller than
women the words on average are implied
pointing to the existence of your friend
rhonda who really is quite tall
does not negate the statistical truth
that on average men are still taller
than women
some of the average differences between
the sexes include that men have more
investigative interests
while women have more artistic and
social interests
men are also on average more interested
in math science and engineering
on tests girls score higher in literacy
while boys score higher in math
and although average intelligence is the
same between boys and girls the
variability in intelligence is not
there are more boy geniuses and more boy
complete dullards than there are girls
in either category
one interesting piece of neuroscience
reveals that across several domains
including both emotional memory and
spatial ability
women are better at details men are
better at gist
this finding manifests for instance in
the average man's superior ability to
remember a route
and the average woman's superior ability
to remember the location of the keys
the cup of coffee the document and need
of being signed
the differences between the sexes are
found in babies and across cultures too
so this is not some weird weird
phenomenon
given a choice neonate girls spend more
time looking at faces
while neonice boys spend more time
looking at things
and across cultures work is gendered
early
in an analysis of 185 cultures in every
culture studied some tasks are always
gendered in the same direction
iron smelting the hunting of large
marine mammals metal working
all of these are done by men only in
those cultures that do these things at
all
more interesting is the tasks that are
highly gendered across cultures but for
which some cultures curtail female
involvement
while other cultures curtail male
involvement these include weaving
the preparation of skins and the
gathering of fuel among others
this suggests that there is a value in
the division of labor even when neither
sex is inherently better at the task
consider also the pueblo people who have
long been understood to be master
ceramicists
it has been it had been assumed given
contemporary patterns that pottery
making was exclusively the domain of
women
in chaco canyon however in the four
corners area of the american southwest
a different story is emerging when chaco
canyon was a rapidly growing religious
and political center one thousand years
ago
the population was expanding and with it
the demand for pottery
more and more vessels were needed to
carry and store grain and water so
gender norms loosened
and men began doing this otherwise
highly gendered work
what might we learn from these truths we
can learn that gender roles can be
re-upped for modernity
some men will prefer hearth and home to
a grueling career that is facilitated by
having a spouse taking care of the
domestic duties
and some women will prefer the latter
but many men and women we argue will
prefer
excuse me but many men and women we
argue will prefer to be restricted to
neither domain
without being slotted into preconceived
roles many people of both sexes will
prefer a partner who is their equal
without being identical
we can learn from a more nuanced
understanding of gendered work
the traditionalist appeals to women not
working outside of the home or to men
being dominant in economic and business
matters
are regressive without any nugget of
necessity or truth
historically women and men have had
division of labor both in family units
and in societies
but other than those tasks mandated by
anatomy and physiology
gestation lactation there is little in
the modern world that some women might
not choose to do
similarly men are ever more welcome in
traditionally female fields such as
nursing and teaching
although we shouldn't expect parity
there either
different preferences lead to different
choices pretending that we are identical
rather than ensuring that we are equal
under the law is a fool's game
and one more so we we have a corrective
lens section at the end of every chapter
and the final one for this chapter
is recognize that our differences
contribute to our collective strength
if we more highly value the work that
women are more likely to be drawn to
eg teaching social work nursing perhaps
we could stop demanding equal
representation of men and women in
fields that women are simply not as
likely to be interested in
recognizing that we are on average
different is the critical first step to
building a society
in which all opportunities are truly
open to everyone
equal opportunity is an honorable goal
in step with reality
whereas aiming for equal outcome in
which every occupation from daycare
workers to garbage collectors has equal
representation between the sexes will
disappoint everyone involved
yeah i i always wonder if those who
apply these very
naive equalizing kinds of
remedy proposals if they have
contemplated what it would be like
to live in the world that they are
imagining
yeah i mean and this came up in the in
that event that uh
that i did years ago now with james
damore in the wake of the google memo
um this this was very much in this and
that had peter pagozian
and helen plecos as well and you
introduced us um back before we lived in
portland but it was an event here
at portland state university um exactly
exactly this
came up right like we also don't
hear the cry from the the gender
activists
uh for there to be equity
in the sexes among garbage collectors
right there's
plenty of dangerous or banal or dirty
work that men are far more likely to do
and no that doesn't pay particularly
well and we're not hearing that we need
equity there
what we're hearing about is in those
fields and i actually in that event i
pushed back against james
james damore a little bit um because
it is true that um the work
that uh men are more likely on average
to be interested in doing does pay
better and this does have to do
with historical record of sexism like
and we have inherited that and this is
you know
in this way unlike in many ways um the
modern manifestations of sexism do
mirror the modern manifestations of
racism where we have inherited
an historical set of of policies
uh most of which don't exist now but
they're but their
ghosts do right the manifestations
downstream still do
well i believe what you've just said is
accurate
but i want to add another category here
so there is some sort of
structural inherited bias
against work that has traditionally been
female
but there's also an economic reason that
that would exist that has nothing to do
with any kind of bigotry
right that because women are
saddled with or privileged with
whichever way you want to see it
the actual production of babies and
their nursing
the economic model would predict
that that would be budgeted in right and
so that
well i mean i think i know i interrupted
you but
you know as we moved to agriculture
tennis 10 to 12-ish thousand years ago
you know most of us um have ancestors
that became agriculturalists
10 to 12 000 years ago as that
as that began to happen you know
for a while everyone was working to
support their own
family and that might have been extended
family but
as trade became more common the things
that men were doing
were tradable and therefore monetizable
and the things that women were doing
were less tradable and monetizable until
very very recently and there are a lot
of us who think that that
monetizing of things like you know of
reproduction and sex
obviously sex has been monetized forever
but um you know things like surrogacy
um is a brand new phenomenon but for the
most part the things that are mandated
by anatomy and physiology
that women do was not brought into the
market
except for you know actually having sex
you know prostitution is super old as we
all know
um and so the the work that men were
doing you know being able to sell the
grain to allow for
um to purchase things that you couldn't
make at home
uh was was something that tracked men's
work and not women's work
and you know we can we could think of
you know putting up the food you know
preserving the food
that was for a while anyway more women's
work but it also didn't generate nearly
as much
of the potential revenue and so you have
this sort of you know
initial um inherent inequality
not based inherently on any bigotry
right not based in in any bigotry
now it doesn't mean it's not structural
it is and it doesn't mean it can't be
structurally corrected it can
um but the point is let's you know it's
tempting to just simply
demonize a system that has biases in it
and then those jump to bigotry is the
only possible bigotry is the explanation
um and then as long as you're doing that
the other temptation is to do it
unevenly so all the crappy stuff that
uh men end up doing you know nobody's
all that eager to democratize that right
the
the dying as you're fending off tyranny
the you know descending into the sewers
to break up
giant globs of fat right i mean right
like
these are not things that women are in
general
trying to break into so anyway there is
something to be done there's
always questions of fairness with
respect to access
but come on these things just aren't
simple right
no they're they're really very much not
like i love that work that um that
i was reading about with 185 uh
pre-agriculturalist societies or yeah
pre-industrial societies and i have but
you know
i used to teach with this a lot i used
to use use that work to teach
descriptive statistics
among other things um but i think it you
know
everything in this book got so shortened
because it has such breadth um
but the point there about division of
labor
persisting in across cultures across
for many activities but which sex
does it varies is extraordinary i love
this the fact that in some cultures
weaving is very much a man's job and
women shall not touch it because it
would you know
sully the the weaving or the men or
something and in other cultures it's
exactly the opposite story and of course
the languaging around it will come will
be different
both because it's different cultures and
because the reasons that we say that
women shouldn't touch things and men
shouldn't touch things tend to be
different as well
but you know weaving well that's man's
work
weaving that's women's work okay both
things are argued in different cultures
at the same time on the planet
and that tells us there's value and
division of labor without those
divisions of labor inherently having
anything to do with underlying
differences
in ability or interest and the fact that
that one goes in both directions tells
us that both
men and women leave well enough alone
okay that one will accept you'll accept
yes
all right yeah um okay so there's a few
there's just there there's always stuff
going on in
in culture about sex and gender so uh
i'd like to just talk about a couple of
them
right now okay um actually zach
i didn't figure out which of the which
part of this five minute video to show
so maybe we won't show it
uh let me don't pull up my screen just
yet
okay i guess i guess
here um
there is um harvard lecturer
i think she clarifies that she is not
actually a professor carol hooven
uh who joined fox and friends for uh
joint that's their language that she
would not say that she's you know she's
a she's a liberal
um who spoke to fox for a four or five
minute clip
um to talk about the ideology that is
happening in um
in education and specifically the
medical medical school specifically the
harvard medical school
and i think they found her through um
katie herzog's recent excellent piece
that was in barry rice's
substance so that's a that's a lot of
names um but
um dr huben here talks about uh male and
female being different
and uh us being able to talk about men
and women being critical in a medical
school and being able to say things like
pregnant women
and i will i will link to this in the in
the show notes but rather than have you
listen to the whole five minutes
you know i listen to it it's not that
long um and there's exactly
nothing transphobic or harmful in what
she says
and yet here we have someone um
tweeting out this video saying a woman
by the name of laura simon lewis saying
as the director of the diversity and
inclusion task force for my department
at harvard
heb that's um human evolution and
behavior i think
i am appalled and frustrated by the
transphobic and harmful remarks made by
a member of my department in this
interview with fox and friends
um to which i re i quote treated as an
evolutionary biologist i am appalled and
frustrated by the scientific illiteracy
that is apparently being facilitated by
our most elite institutions
um i don't
i don't honestly know how we are going
to continue
to function if this continues i mean
this
we're seeing incompetence and inability
to think through
basic scientific arguments over in
virus and vaccine space
at least that's a little bit complicated
at least it takes
walking through a few steps of logic to
arrive where people should
be arriving at but the
observation that everyone on the earth
has made
that male and female are different and
the
fact that in our lineage alone we have
at least
500 million years of uninterrupted
sexual reproduction in our lineage
and sex has been around sexual
reproduction has been around for
oh anywhere from one to two billion
years on the planet and
probably our uninterrupted lineage goes
back that far as well that 500 million
years
number that i quoted that's just that's
me being conservative
like yes intersex people exist and
yes gender and here you and i always
have a slightly different
um definition for this gender is the
behavioral manifestation of sex
in non-human animals what we call uh
gender in humans we call sex role
and you know the way that you manifest
your sex
is your sex role is your gender are
there some humans
who feel deep down that they are
not the sex that they are born to yes
and
they are transgendered and we will treat
them with respect and we need to do so
but
this this has got to stop this has
got to stop this is insanity it's
you're absolutely right it is going to
result in the destruction
of everything as as we pointed out a
long time ago
um you know if your schools of
engineering
are going postmodern then the point is
you're giving an advantage to any
competitor who can manage not to suffer
that same fate
right and so basically we're talking you
know on a global scale
of those societies that can resist this
nonsense are going to have
you know the gates of the city thrown
open to them
true but but in the meantime bridges may
start falling right
and in the meantime as medical schools
are captured and cannot agree to
like really the easiest and most basic
observable fact of human biology
right i mean if they started saying that
humans have three legs i'd find that
more plausible
right right like if if this is gonna
this is gonna be killing people because
guess what as we you know as we go
through the evidence you know very very
briefly in a different part of this
chapter
you know the number of medical
conditions
that manifest differently not just in
frequency
but in but with regard to etiology that
is what causes them and with regard to
symptoms how they manifest
bisex is huge and growing all the time
and a that's going to start disappearing
we're not going to be able to know about
it the research isn't going to be
allowed and people are going to arrive
in hospitals presenting with things
where if
you don't even get to know as a doctor
what sex
is we're going and it's and it's largely
frankly probably
um going to affect more women than men
so j
just as just as
the vast majority of medical research
until the mid 20th century was done
on on men and it was assumed that what
was true for men was true for everyone
it was pretty recently that we started
seeing
a recognition that men and women reveal
disease differently
and this improved women's health care
well this is just going to take us right
back
well i think it's even worse than that
you know you know
yeah well of course wouldn't i um
if you think about the game that we play
politically
right where we force you to effectively
engage in a
career of uh legal corruption
before you can get to the highest
echelons of
leadership right so we force you to
prove that you will make the mental
the moral compromises in order to play
that game
before we ever learn your name as a
senator or you know presidential
candidate or anything like that
in this case it's effectively imagine
that what we did was we just said okay
from now on we are going to ask people a
question before we let them into medical
school
do you agree that men can get pregnant
right
and if the answer is well no men can't
get pregnant sorry you're not qualified
for medical school
right then you get a medical school in
which everybody agrees men can get
pregnant the question is what is the
quality of what will take place at a
medical school where you had that as a
gate
right the answer is that's not going to
be much of a medical school because what
you've just done
is demonstrated that everybody there is
a coward
or a fool or some combination of those
things
and if you you know build a medical
school of cowards and fools it's not
going to be a high quality one so
at some level you have to empower people
to be able to say look
i get it that it's really unpleasant
that there are you know
two sexes and that we can distinguish
them uh you know
immediately on birth except in very rare
cases right
um but the fact is come on
you cannot allow these things to take
over essential functions and essential
functions means not only
things like medicine and governance but
also things like
the military right increasingly we are
feminizing our military
which you know from the point of view of
uh
us empathizing better with each other
there's an argument to be made for
from the point of view of the ability
to have a you know unique gender profile
what you really need is a
powerful masculine military to protect
the freedom that allows you to figure
out how you want to live
right if you say well that freedom
should exist in the military too and
why is this military regimen you know so
dictatorial shouldn't it be democratic
and
you know shouldn't we figure out you
know let's not make a military move
until everybody's had a chance to speak
right
i mean you can imagine applying these
rules being well intentioned but my god
you're going to create a system that
cannot function
yeah chain of command goes right out the
window yeah it sure does yeah
um okay show my screen just for a minute
zach here's a guardian article
from when is it uh two days ago
ioc that's the international olympic
committee praises weightlifter laurel
hubbard before transgender athlete's
olympic debut
uh if i may have my screen back so this
um this person laurel hubbard i think
is going to debut on monday so has not
happened
yet i'm just gonna quote a few more
places from the article but from my
screen so don't don't show
zach the ioc's medical and science
director dr richard
richard budget said quote everyone
agrees that trans women
are women hubbard's participation in
tokyo hubbard being the athlete
has proved controversial with her
supporters hailing at his historic
moment for trans rights
with the ioc's critics believing that
the 42 year old new zealander
who had never competed internationally
until transitioning at 35
has an unfair and substantial advantage
final quote recent scientific papers
have also shown that anyone who
undergoes male puberty retains
significant advantages in power and
strength even after taking medication to
suppress their testosterone levels
and one of the papers you know you don't
say right one of the papers that they
cite here
or maybe the only paper is this
excellent paper by emma hilton and tommy
lundberg
that just came out and that we managed
to just sneak into our book just before
final final edits were done called
transgender women in the female category
of sport
perspectives on testosterone suppression
and performance advantage
so one thing i want to say here is you
know slight kudos to the guardian
for actually you know this is it's it's
not it's by no means a perfect piece
um but the guardian has been a sort of
canary in the coal mine of
of woke ridiculousness for a while now
and
um is that can i thank you um has been a
canary in the coal mine for woke
of woke ridiculousness for a while now
but
this piece actually has um not just some
nuance but actually some truth
and you know having just just simply
putting it out there
that the ioc's medical and science
director
says everyone agrees that trans women
are women well
no no they don't and if you've
if you've got a degree and you're the
director of both medicine and science
the fact that you can say that means
you're not fit for your job
yeah like you're just not and you know
who cares a 35 year old person
transitions never having competed before
and now seven years later is in the
olympics
in weightlifting it's not even
like fencing right which like like
everything is sex segregated
everything is sex segregated but
weightlifting for christ's sakes yeah
like
even our pelvises being differently
shaped
makes men more stable on their feet
this is insanity yeah like
i can't believe we're here i can't
believe we're here right and
you know that it's heralded as a major
victory for trans rights when it's
actually a major setback for women
right yes so so so disappear
women's sports right and in fact um i
just want to read a small bit from
this book helen joyce's trans when
ideology meets reality this just came
out this month
we got a preview copy and i have not
read the whole thing i
have skimmed it all and read some of it
and it is as i was expecting
um quite excellent and she does a
section on
um on basically a history
of of females of female sports as well
which i didn't i didn't know and is
quite interesting and basically
you know like with like with the
recognition that women
have different ideologies and
manifestations of disease and we need to
recognize that in our health care
practices in order not to be killing
women because we think they're just men
but smaller
so too um have just recently
women been um not just allowed to
compete at the elite levels
um but been given their you know our own
places to do so because when women
compete directly with men
unless it's in something that is
explicitly co-ed like mixed doubles in
tennis or you know the sport that we
played a lot of
ultimate frisbee really allows for
wonderful games when they're co-ed
and you know i played i played a lot of
co-ed frisbee i played competitively on
the
women's team at university of michigan
and watched therefore in a lot of
tournaments
a lot of men's play a lot of women's
play a lot of co-ed play
and frankly in that particular game and
there are a lot of games that
a lot of sports that don't allow for it
but in that particular game
co-ed he's going to knock that over just
move that
coed play allows for the best of both
right like well well hold on a second
for those who haven't played it
it's specifically neutralizes the
problem
right if you take the big dude on the
ultimate team and he teams up against
the
the little they're doing a man on he
lines up against a woman right and
that's who he's
he'll shut her down and that's
considered unfair so the idea is when
you line up before
a particular point you line up against
somebody with whom you are appropriately
matched so it can be a man against a
woman if they're appropriately matched
but the point is it neutralizes
the ability of men to shut down women
right but i mean also if you're playing
zone rather than man on defense that
that further neutralizes it but you do
need i mean it's understood that you
need to have
uh an equivalent or you know usually an
equivalent sex ratio on both teams
if you've got you know and this is true
in um co-ed competition
where um i think you're it's been a
while since i played i've ruptured my
achilles tendon doing so
um i think you're always required to
have two women
um on at a time and um basically if you
claim you're a co-ed team and you only
have men on the
on the on the field at the time um
you're not
effectively playing co-ed but what i was
going to say is
um an all an all-male game which are
fun to watch um you know there's just
this raw physicality
um but they tend to be long hucks and
fast runs into the end zone you know
layouts spectacular all of this but the
points are short
most people don't touch the disc a lot
of people don't get play
and many beers are held no
but you know in women's games um it
tends to be
um almost the opposite like a lot of
short passes a lot of focus on making
sure
not in the competitive stuff there's not
as much focus on like make sure everyone
touches the desk but
you know shorter passes fewer long hawks
longer points
um gets a little tedious and you know i
never liked playing the women's the
women's game as much as i liked playing
the co-ed games because it has both
because there is more strategy and focus
on how are you going to do this if
you've got some
you got some six foot six guy who's
going to show up and
shut you down any time you get the disc
you got it you've got to think
strategically
and realize that your strength isn't
necessarily in
raw power and size and speed right
so anyway in in that case and it won't
be the case in a lot of team sports but
in that case there is actually a way to
play co-ed that is wonderful and i would
say you know that's what that's what
life offers as well let me just read one
paragraph from the introduction of
helen joyce's new book
um she begins by saying no just just one
paragraph here
this is a book about trans activism it
is a story about
policy and institutional capture of
charitable foundations controlled by
billionaires joining forces with
activist groups to pump money into
lobbying behind the scenes for legal
change
they have won over big political parties
notably america's democrats and big
businesses including
tech giants they are backed too by
academics and gender studies
queer theory and allied fields and by
the pharmaceutical and healthcare
industries which have woken up to the
fortunes to be made
from gender affirming medicine so
it's the same everywhere right we got
the same kind of story
everywhere we got capture and activism
that may or may not be coordinated but
um its effect is as if it was
yeah and i uh you know i hate that this
is now
manifesting in new realms but really the
point is
this was what uh we were trying to warn
people about when we were talking about
um the danger that capture and
corruption
poses to our ability to function
coherently and you know the fact that
you're seeing it across
uh the social media platforms the fact
that you're seeing it in science
medicine
health policy um you know our military
everything the fact that everything is
susceptible to being pushed into insane
uh contortions is just evidence that we
have a very serious problem
right and you know evergreen many people
took to be
uh almost funny in how over the top it
was
but it was a warning right this is what
corruption does to a system it renders
it incoherent
and an incoherent system doesn't
collapse immediately but at the point
you recognize that these
you know falsehoods have taken over the
steering mechanism
it's an emergency whether or not there's
an iceberg visible right there's going
to be one at some point
yep all right
last week uh you had us use a thumbnail
with a
b in a flower and obviously that should
have been the thumbnail for this week
damn on sex and gender oh right twice
over
you were arguing the bee was sleeping
somehow
is that what i i think i argued it was
going to sleep
at some point yeah i wasn't sleeping
right no matter
um so do we have a thumbnail for this
week i'm hoping you do
um we are going to end here
we are going to for those uh listening
be back in a week
and for those watching if you want to
partic partake in
our live q a we'll take a 50 minute
break or the minimum amount it takes to
get the new
the the new odyssey link up uh ask us
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
recognize that we appreciate
the money that you give us for those
questions but we make no promises that
we will get to
to all of them and we are increasingly
prioritizing those that seem apropos
what we were talking about
or you know otherwise interesting or
irrelevant to us there is now an option
to
um to vote on questions as well and we
look at those votes although they don't
um
really affect uh whether or not um you
know if some question gets a ton a ton
of votes we may we may
pay particular attention to it um
consider joining our patreons
consider coming over to uh natural
selections my new
sub stack newsletter all of the writing
is going to be free i'm going to be
doing for paid subscribers
audio reads of my of my tuesday essays
but all of the writing is free so if you
subscribe that just means you get an
email from me whenever i post something
new which will be tuesdays occasionally
more frequently
consider going to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
to check out those goliath t-shirts and
please if you want a goliath t-shirt go
there don't buy it from some other party
because they have
stolen that from us email any questions
that you have with regard to logistics
not with regard to questions that you
would like us to answer in the q a
to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
and consider subscribing to all four of
our channels we've got two on youtube
two on odyssey brett weinstein's main
channel which is where you're seeing
this on both and
darkhorse podcast clips which of course
has
clips and like this video
share it anything else
uh achieve greatness stand up for what's
right
and we will see you soon
and be good to the ones you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
you